what's going on Alan Dru here El copy go
and today we're going to be breaking
down some insanely good copyrighting ads
three really compelling ads some of my
favorite ads of all but before we dive
in please do me a very quick favor hit
like on this video if you want to see
more content like this go ahead and hit
the subscribe on the channel so I know
that you want me to continue making
videos to make you an even better
copywriter so with that said and done
and now that you've done that let's go
ahead and Dive Right In all right I've
whipped together a document here to make
this really really easy in fact I've
made this document accessible to you so
if you like what I'm about to show you
you can grab and save the document for
yourself so that way you can have it
whenever you just got to hit the link in
the description below you put in your
email and I'll send it to you okay all
right so insanely good copyrighting ads
the first ad that I want to break down
is one of my favorite ads by timx now
I'm a big watch gu so this one resonated
with me ton I wear a mechanical watch or
analog watch whatever I don't wear a
smart watch so I thought this was really
hilarious uh and funny so in navigating
that you have the big billboard the
white billboard with the one watch very
simple clean I like that design
aesthetic And the tagline is no the time
without seeing you have 100 2,000 I'm
sorry
1,249 unanswer to emails that's a great
tagline let me break that down what that
means cuz there is a lot lot to unpack
there first off uh before we break it
down actually the the thing that you got
to know obviously is that who they're
taking a jab at why this actually makes
sense and that is because the context of
the ad we live in the Smartwatch era so
the context of this ad wouldn't have
worked in the 80s and the 90s when big
copywriters like Gary Halper Gary Baba
John Carlton when these guys were
putting out ads so so that's important
because the context of what makes the ad
powerful is as powerful as the ad itself
right the copyrighting itself has to
culturally make sense and this obviously
makes sense because they're taking a jab
at smart watches so understanding your
industry why you're writing what you're
writing and what people are going
through personally this is talking to
the reader because your ideal reader
hopefully is wearing a watch right but
their problem is that they're frustrated
with the watch and this is one of the
frustrations and let's break this down a
little bit right let me give you some
Logistics as to why this ad is so good
and then some extra context is one know
the time that is a benefit clear benefit
it's so simple though is that watch
owners like myself simply want to look
at our rist and know the time and it
seems like watch makers have lost their
way because they've stuffed so much into
a watch the Smartwatch category is that
it's not just know the time it's know
your calendar and check your messages
and check your emails and check the
weather and and try track your runs and
all these things and they sell it as
such an amazing thing however this one
is coming back down to the core benefit
which I love in an ad so the unique
selling proposition the USP is no the
time very simple and simplicity often
wins an advertisement right and then the
next part I want to stop at the without
without is a great way to make your ad
even more unique and what that's called
is it's a constraint so a lot of times
people will be like lose 10 lbs without
giving up carbs okay that without is a
constraint and so they use that
constraint here know the time without
right and then they're going to talk
about the other side of it but that's a
really smart play in advertising you
want to add a constraint whatever to
make it more unique to whatever you're
selling so know the time without without
what seeing that you have
1,249 unanswered emails
now one thing that I do want to point
out is the
1,249 that real specific number just
makes it believable right it makes it
feel real it makes it feel like you
genuinely looked at your Smartwatch and
saw 1,24 they could have said a th000
without 3,000 unread emails and those
numbers just fake feel uh those numbers
feel factitious they feel fake they feel
like they're not well put together that
somebody just kind of slapped it there
and then those specific numbers feel
intentional now that increases the
believability of your ad and obviously
the more that people believe your ad the
more likely that they'll buy from your
ad so that's really really important and
then the last part I labeled as emotion
and you're like emotion I don't get it
you have to think about this without
seeing that you have
1,249 unanswered EMS that is emotional
imagine looking at your watch your
Smartwatch and and seeing that you have
so many that's
overwhelming you just want to know the
time and so you look at your watch and
you feel like oh my God I got to catch
up with Al how many people are and you
feel overwhelmed and so the Simplicity
of this really Nails it so scrolling
back up to the ad when you see that when
you see the Simplicity of the watch the
white background the one line it's just
like don't you just want to know the
time without seeing that you have all
this crap to do great ad really
emotionally driven really understands
the target reader really simple
unique selling proposition one of my
favorites all right hope you enjoy that
let's keep going the next one is buy New
Balance which by the way every ad that
I'm showing you here are companies that
I've personally bought stuff from and
this is one of the ways that I dissect
ads is because I actually try and find
hey what makes me interested that I'm
willing to pull out my own money and
spend with these companies often times
dissecting your own buying habits will
teach you more about copyrighting than
anything else because it'll teach you to
understand the feelings that persuaded
you into buy okay so New Balance I
actually I didn't buy New Balance off
this ad but I've had New Balances for a
long time when I saw this ad I said this
is Wonder All right so New Balance worn
by supermodels in London and dads in
Ohio okay lot to break down here this
now this is not a true direct response
copyrighting ad so some of the purist in
here might be like Allan give me
something better to dissect this is more
of like a brand ad however when you see
this you are definitely more attached to
the brand and you understand that um
there's only a few things that a one
brand could say that no other brand can
say and New Balance has taken that to
the next level where it's very few
things that it's it it's very few other
brands out there that can say worn by
supermodels in London and dads in Ohio
very few brands that could say that and
so when you find the thing that your
brand is so uniquely equipped to say and
just saying that part that infinitely
makes your out a lot better so if I were
to say the most comfortable sneaker out
there okay that's a benefit it's a line
it's all but anybody can say that Adidas
can say that Nike can say that and you
balance is saying worn by supermodels in
London and dads in oh high very unlikely
that almost any other brand can say that
now let me break down the line in itself
is the first one and the most obvious
thing is the jux the position
supermodels jux supposes dads London
jxap poses Ohio okay and so that ju the
position has fantastic imagery where
you're like oh my gosh the contrast
makes it more real like oil and vinegar
you see the separation and when you see
that you feel it you think about it it's
imagery in your mind and so it actually
brings it to like you start picturing a
supermodel in London wearing you bounces
and Dad's in Ohio cutting the grass
wearing New Balances and so that CHX the
position really makes you think a lot
more about it really great way or
contrast if you want to think about it a
little bit more simply the next thing is
relatability what you might be wanting
to be like a supermodel dressing fashion
brand right or you might be a dad in I
I'm a dad I'm not an Ohio but I'm a dad
and so when you kind of wear you're like
that's kind of hilarious yeah like Norm
guys like me are wearing the same
clothes as these high fashioned people
kind of funny and so it's just relatable
it makes it feel like your reader could
honestly be anyone which is very ironic
because typically you want to Target one
specific very Niche or reader and new
balot can really conquer and say
honestly everybody wears our shoes
really cool and then lastly specificity
you're going to see that sprinkled
throughout but they could have just said
warn by people in the UK as as well as
people in the US right that's so broad
or like worn by ladies in the UK and
worn by guys in the U no they said worn
by
supermodels in London and dads in Ohio
you're getting really specific with it
okay but not so specific that it's like
worn by Vanessa hudgin as well as blah
blah blah I mean you can that's
celebrity marketing but overall great
line great J position super simple which
you'll notice about all these ads
and so that's that's a great one you can
steal that one for your headline bank
now let's go to the last one and the
last one you might have seen a million
times or this might be your first time
seeing it but it would be a dishonor for
me to not break this ad down for you so
Apple of course we all probably have
owned or own an Apple product this is by
far one of the best copyrighting lines
ever to exists okay iPod 1,000 songs in
your pocket again just Apple doing what
they do best simplicity at its finest
let's break down this line first one
being Simplicity I just mentioned it
sometimes we
complicate copyrighting so much we think
of all these benefits and we make all
this writing and things and we think
that our writing is going to persuade it
but at the end of the day actually this
ad hits so hard because of its
Simplicity specifically I'm stealing
some context from Hemingway who very
very well he wasn't a copywriter but he
was a writer and one of the reasons he
was so popular as a writer was that he
wrote at such a um easyto read level a
fifth grade level in fact Joe Sugarman
teaches that in his book the adwe
copyrighting handbook is that the
average American reads at a fifth grade
level which means using simple words
that they truly understand and nothing
sophisticated and this add a thousand
songs in your pocket is so dead simple
that
anybody could understand that but it's
it's not easy to get to this point
because when you look at this there's
all kinds of ways that they that they
could have run this ad they could have
said 5 gigabyt of storage now available
the only blah blah blah they could have
done all that and it wouldn't have made
any sense it would have be like huh
what's that what's 5 gabes of storage
like what is this and they could have
made just really fancy complicated
verbage but they didn't do that they
took it down to his Essence and it said
what is the specific simple benefit like
what does this thing do and what it does
with all that storage and all that stuff
the benefit to the reader is a th000
songs in your pocket it's small enough
to fit in your pocket and it has enough
storage to put a th000 songs on it so
simple but often times we even say
things like small enough to fit in your
pocket big enough to hold a th000 songs
even that is more complicated it's a
good line but even that is more
complicated than just saying a thousand
songs in your pocket bearing it down any
time you could say the same thing in
less words your copy will be better and
this is an a perfect example of that
obviously specificity a thousand songs
instead of saying a lot of songs in your
pocket you say a thousand songs that's
obviously better and then the benefit
this is the other part that is really
really important because a lot of the
engineers wanted to talk about the
breakthrough in the iPod because at that
time a huge breakthrough was 5 GB nobody
had ever put 5 GB in a music player now
in 2024 2025 sounds crazy you're like
what I've got like a million gigabytes
of everything right exactly but when
they dropped this there was no such
thing and so 5 GB they want to be like
we have to tell
people but your ideal customer had no
idea what that meant they're like is
that a lot is that a little is that good
how many songs is that like how much
data does that do and and so that's a
feature of the product 5 GB is a feature
of the product what is the benefit of
that feature and the benefit of that
feature is 1,000 songs the user
experiences the benefit not the feature
the feature talks about us the benefit
talks about them and whenever you're
writing copy you always want to talk
about your customer
never about yourself cuz it's about
solving their problems and this is one
of the best ways to do that so great
line those are three great ads one from
Timex New Balance and apple and if you
like this breakdown let me know I hope
that I can make you some more just by
your feedback so before you head out was
this helpful and if it was go to my
website Allen dru.com join my email list
where I give you copyrighting tips every
single day once a day I will jump into
your inbox and give you some
copyrighting tips tell you some amazing
Stories and in fact when you join my
email list I give you a gift I give you
copyrighting Catalyst which is 67 cash
cow copyrighting tips just for you to
study enjoy and learn copyrighting today
super simple super easy I hope this
video was great for you and I'll catch
you on the next one